[Musique]
j'ai pas me prendre avec les gens
il ya une chose que je sais faire c'est
la mission était de découvrir ce qu'ils
savaient mais ce sera difficile
maintenant que vous les avez tous tués
je crois pas que vous êtes fait pour le
renseignement c'est votre dernière
chance
daval écoles au monde y est à de la
confiture partout dans le visage le 7e
titre afta c'est trop tard pour faire
l'école à la maison et qui vous est
blessé à les commenter entre les poumons
et le film on était en streaming sikkim
apprend qu'une fillette de 9 ans nous a
découvert ma carrière évident mais
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
battus et simule un accident what être
les escaliers encore on fait un marché
qui montera et une espionne qu'on
s'entende bien c'est exceptionnel
après c'est fini wally géré par temps
commence si les parcours de pâques ou
comment voir la foule pendant
l'explosion polygraphe je peux sentir
les mensonges les endorphines ont une
odeur et au mensonge chez lui au moindre
battement de cils agents dédiés amir
toutes et à tous
jeudi je suis persuadé qu'à jamais plus
à des stéroïdes
hu tout à l'heure tu regardes la barre
qui tu vois 90 civils dans un périmètre
mal sécurisés là dedans sourit en tennis
et c'est ce qu'elle fera du bien
[Musique]
ah bon tour
l'objectif de cet exercice est d'arriver
à me contourner direct le meilleur moyen
serait causé une distraction sinon tu
seras jamais capable de perdre des 10
il est gentil
[Musique]
mikit qui peut en dire est la scène du
mariage la fin de shrek
cette saison dans la flamme 13 femmes
vont devoir se battre pour le coeur d'un
seul homme
activation des petits boutons alors marc
la femme de votre vie vous l'imaginez
comment elle doit être belle je
m'appelle soraya j28 on a very alexandra
je suis juste à la recherche de l'amour
qu'ils aient de la conversation c'est
quoi ta plus grande peur et puis il faut
que tu fasses rien j'aimerais c'est pas
marrant montre là bas vous même pas ce
qu'est ce que vous êtes vous avez deux
lotos des résultats d'accor non pas du
tout voulu souffler dans la bouche mais
l'amour est imprévisible
allez il peu échauffés les querelles en
mai et c'est sûr mais aussi vous voler
sur son passage au quai alexandra
c'était violent sentez-vous ridicule et
des lipides et tu vas me paie c'est ton
quant à l'eau j'ai foutu fait c réactive
aux seconds
je n'ai pas pu tout arrêter de me suivre
parmi ces 13 prétendantes à qui marc
déclara-t-il
sa flamme comment ça va - ouais super et
laventure une catastrophe
et nous traque
non c'est dany tube
pourquoi elle
parce que c'est ça qu'elle a peur venez
aidez moi à 3 2 3
vous allez emmener des lieux sûrs et moi
je vais m'occuper s'est tous sourit
et attends tu vas faire quoi on va
s'amuser un peu tous les deux fait la
sortir d'ici
[Musique]
gratuit ou quoi ce truc va tuer il a
raison ce truc est magique
oui moi aussi
attend il y en a
le style est que l'une est
tu goûtes show qu'il a les mêmes yeux
comme si tout le monde et c'est tout à
fait moi ça j'espère que c'est la seule
chose qui tient de toi et le ciel fait
gardé par qui mais préviennent tu
connais beaucoup de parents qui laissent
leurs enfants à la mine ou un faux bond
mais toujours chez nous peut que nous ne
mélangeons pas tout
jamais
c'est qui
[Musique]
son que je travaille je reviens pourquoi
mon fils est dans les bras de deux
pleins de gens qu'on connaît pas là on a
plus de vie parce qu'on va agir et lui
mais surtout parce qu'on va vous gérez
vos visa cathy et avec moi ils purent
jamais on a une peur parce qu'ils
s'emmerdent avec toi pardon on est
entouré par quatre paris j'ai
l'impression d'être là si l'amour on
allait devoir passer un permis grands
parents un permis qui prouve que vous
êtes
ap et drogba
la lune avoir passé un séjour ensemble
tous les quatre et sans embrouille la
mission assurer la sécurité de bout
d'chou la sécurité avant tout
elle a déjà confié mary jo foley
parmi ces quatre choix lequel ferait le
meilleur donc toi papa tu feras garder
ton petit fils par emile louis je
croyais que c'était joué le rôle du show
[Musique]
salut
est-ce qu'on peut essayer d'avoir un
comportement aussi normale que possible
oui ok pas de souci qui ont fait
certaines tu veux pas fait john duncan a
vraiment du mal à en parler de tuer
mamie non pas du tout c'est illégal pas
vrai comment vous allez faire ça va se
passer quand bientôt maugras ça va oui
d'habitude je ne prends pas ce genre de
la crise
vous dormez je vais bientôt mourir vous
vous joignez à nous ça devrait faire les
fragiles que tu laisses et maman profité
de ce week-end sur que tout tourne
autour de ta personne n'a quoi tu peux
arrêter d'être gars c'est stupide que
j'appellerais le 911 pour signaler une
tentative
mais tu es sûr parce que elle elle a dit
qu'elle était prête elle est prête mais
moi pas
[Musique]
c'est le moment de le faire alors
qu'elle était encore consciente de ce
qui va se passer mais n'a pas peur
depuis qu'on a choisi une date j'ai
arrêté de penser à la mort et j'ai
concentré toute mon énergie sur la vie
cet héritage devra être entièrement
dépensée en coq et ampute
[Musique]
mais t'as quoi dans la tête or qui doit
la laisser faire ce qu'elle veut je veux
mieux la connaître
je veux qu'elle me connaissent mois
[Musique]
mais mes petites filles
donner un conseil pour la vie
le truc c'est juste de se pointer et de
faire de son mieux à cette merveille
qu'est la vie
[Musique]
oh
ok
d
loupé
[Musique]
[ __ ] art
bien sûr
[Musique]
dieu
c'est long
comme dans l'offre que j'ai dit
[Musique]
j'ouvre ici
le sporting
messieurs
m
[Musique]
tiémoko
m
pourquoi
pourquoi je vis pourquoi je me
[Musique]
on
pourquoi je ris pourquoi je pleut
[Musique]
voici leur essence d'un terrien en
détresse
j'ai jamais les pieds sur terre
je voulais prendre
pourquoi je vis le biopic inédit sur
grégory lemarchal bientôt sur tf1 allait
bien dépêche toi
la nuit va bientôt tomber papa a laissé
la flamme allumée papa
nous savions pertinemment qu'ils n'en
avait plus pour longtemps tu peux pas
laisser tout seul je te fais la promesse
aujourd'hui que j'habite sur notre ville
de décines aurons qu'allez vous devenir
vous et votre soeur est ce que vous
connaissez quelqu'un qui aurait besoin
de deux femmes de ménage les 30 marques
qui nous a donné nous même pas suffi à
manger le mois dernier
je ne sais pas quand je pourrai payer
nous sommes depuis 10 714 des souffleurs
de verre et sur des maturités de même
aucune femme autorisé à couple élevé à
risque
à bout de souffle
ce travail dangereux ça suffit tu n'es
pas ma mère
ce petit village apprenait qu'une femme
l'est
ce serait une catastrophe
ce que tu fabriques mais ils en font des
gorges chaudes
il n'y en a qu'un qui décide et ce mois
regardez-moi cauchemar
yoanna
ceci est absurde beaucoup de me croire
une femme n'a jamais soufflé le verger
peu pourri
futile et l'inutile oui mais il apporte
quelque chose de magique dans la vie des
gens